un morto mijail gorbachov el líder
soviético que intentó reformar la uv y
sin embargo tuvo que presidir el final
de este sistema y del comunismo en rusia
gorbachov era muy admirado un occidente
y sin embargo muy cuestionado en rusia
porque en buena medida se le culpaba del
final del anuncio biótica y de las
turbulencias que tuvieron que vivir los
rusos durante los años 90 aún así el
presidente vladimir putin ha transmitido
sus más sinceras condolencias a su
familia por la chef será enterrado en el
cementerio de novodiévichie donde está
enterrada desde el año 99 su querida
esposa antes de gorbachev su figura
histórica destaca sobre todo por su
ansia reformista y también por haber
contribuido a parar la guerra fría
evitando así la amenaza de una tercera
guerra mundial una amenaza que hoy en
día vuelve a cernirse sobre europa tras
la invasión de ucrania por parte de
vladimir putin